out of all the great ancient greek
philosophers there are few that are
more household names than others figures
like plato aristotle and socrates and on
that list is probably also the
mysterious pythagoras
we've all heard his name hell we all had
to learn that theorem in school when we
grew up but what do we actually know
about pythagoras
when i say the name pythagoras what
comes to mind perhaps
scientist ancient greek philosopher
perhaps mathematics and geometry an
ancient proto-scientist interested in
the ways that reality is built on
mathematics and geometry
pretty likely but how about cult leader
shaman and hater of beings probably not
words that you associate with pythagoras
but words that might not be too far off
from the truth and maybe even more
close to the truth than those concepts
that we usually associate with his name
so let's dive into the world of ancient
greece and explore the fascinating life
and movement of pythagoras and the
pythagoreans
[Music]
pythagoras is a so-called pre-socratic
philosopher this means that he is a
figure that lived before socrates and
this speaks to the importance of the
latter figure more than anything else
it is generally believed that pythagoras
lived between the 6th to 5th centuries
bc and is thus one of the earliest
figures of his kind that we know of
now there are a lot of legends
surrounding pythagoras in later periods
he came to represent the originator of
some of the most fundamental
philosophical ideas and currents that
were believed to be carried on by
figures like plato and many others he's
sometimes even called the first
philosopher and holds a very high status
and role in the western philosophical
tradition
there is thus a tendency to project
later ideas and developments backwards
onto pythagoras but
can we somehow remove all these myths
and get an idea of who the real
historical pythagoras was
possibly but not without some struggle
the later self-proclaimed followers of
pythagoras the so-called pythagoreans
came to make up a distinct group in
antiquity and were characterized by
specific ideas and a particular
pythagorean way of life
aspects of which might be traceable to
the man himself but as the intro
suggested it might not be what you
expect
so who was he then well as i'm sure
you're used to hearing by this point the
sources really aren't on our side
pythagoras himself never wrote anything
he wrote no texts no books and most
accounts of his life often come
centuries after he died
did he even exist probably but it can be
difficult to
tell legend from historical truth in
general some of the later sources that
describe his life and teachings may
indeed of course have their source in
earlier traditions and the existence of
a somewhat continuous quote unquote
pythagorean way of life followed by
people at the time can be helpful in
tracing these traditions back to his own
time
especially useful for us are the
so-called accusmata sayings attributed
to pythagoras himself which sometimes
include direct references to the way of
life that he is said to have taught the
most complete accounts of his life come
in the third and fourth centuries ce or
a.d we have two works entitled the life
of pythagoras from this time one by
diogenes lyricist and another by
porphyry
we also have a work called on the
pythagorean life by the famous
neoplatonist iamblicus these are all
written 800 years after pythagoras
supposedly lived and don't exactly
strive for historical objectivity but
there are aspects of them that can be
used we also have more fragmentary
mentions earlier on in writings by
people like aristotle and even earlier
figures that are more trustworthy for
that reason but these accounts are not
as complete so with this in mind what do
we got
pythagoras was born and grew up on the
island of samos basically nothing at all
is known about his early life but some
claim that he would have traveled a lot
to places like babylon and especially
egypt to learn the so-called wisdoms of
the egyptians
indeed pythagoras is especially
associated with egyptian wisdoms and
some of his ideas claimed to have come
from that land originally now we should
keep in mind that this was a very common
trope back then and it shouldn't
necessarily be taken as entirely true in
any case at some point when he was
around 40 years old he moved to the
greek city of kroton in southern italy
and it is here that he really enters
history at least relatively
he starts gathering followers and
espousing his teachings and way of life
indeed by all accounts pythagoras became
quite famous during his own lifetime as
a kind of sage his fame didn't come from
some mathematical theories or
quote-unquote philosophy in the regular
sense of that word but rather as a kind
of wonder-working sage who could perform
amazing superhuman feats and who led a
group of followers that followed a
certain pythagorean way of life which
included rituals and rules that seemed
and still kind of seem pretty weird
the view of pythagoras as a kind of
magical being is found all over the
sources aristotle retells a few stories
quote the son of nicomachus in other
words aristotle adds that pythagoras was
once seen by many people on the same day
and at the same hour both at metapontum
and at croton
and at olympia during the games he got
up in the theater and showed that one of
his thighs was golden which was a sign
of divinity
the same rider says that while crossing
the cosas he was hailed by the river and
that many people heard him so healed
it is also told that pythagoras
supposedly killed a deadly biting
serpent by biting it himself which is
incredibly badass and a bunch of similar
stories in other words the reputation
that pythagoras had at the time
according to many people was not as some
scientific philosopher that word didn't
really even exist at that point but
rather as a kind of semi divine being
who had
very significant psychic and spiritual
powers i used the word shaman in the
intro and that word should rarely be
employed and it doesn't really work here
either but you can kind of see why some
people have gravitated towards calling
him a shaman he had secret wisdoms and
performed practices that allowed him to
be in multiple places at the same time
perhaps his soul could travel to
different realms and other such juicy
things and that point about the soul is
very important because it actually
segues nicely into the actual teachings
that he is associated with indeed
pythagoras seems to have taught that the
soul is distinct from the body that it
is immortal and survives after the
body's death this was a quite unusual
teaching at the time but would be picked
up by many in the future including of
course plato this is one of those things
that he might indeed have gotten from
the egyptians who indeed did believe in
a post-mortem life for the soul or souls
sometimes
after the body dies the immortal soul is
then reborn into another body
that's right pythagoras most likely
taught the theory of reincarnation
this is perhaps most colorfully
indicated in a story that appears in
both xenophonies and diogenes
literature's life of pythagoras quotes
once they said that he was passing by
when a puppy was being whipped and he
took pity and said stop do not beat it
for it is the soul of a friend that i
recognized when i heard it screaming
in this somewhat comical but telling
story pythagoras recognizes that it is
the soul of an old friend that has
reincarnated as this particular dog
we don't know much at all about the
details of pythagoras theory of
reincarnation in other spots it seems
like he imagines the soul to be subject
to a kind of divine judgment after death
where it can be punished in the
underworld or have a more pleasant
afterlife maybe this is connected
somehow to the nature of reincarnation
but we simply don't know what is clear
is that pythagoras was seen as an expert
on the nature of the soul and its fate
after death
we're beginning to get a new idea of who
this guy was or at least claimed to be a
person who knew a thing or two about the
soul and could perhaps even manipulate
his own soul to do really cool tricks
and so it isn't perhaps that surprising
that he made quite a name for himself
and that he managed to gather a devoted
group of followers in croton these first
pythagoreans would have been like a
little secret society gathering around
their teachers to learn esoteric
teachings and practices and they were
especially characterized as i've alluded
to already by following a certain
pythagorean way of life this was in fact
what pythagoras and his followers were
mostly famous for having a specific set
of rules and ritual conducts that made
them stand out and here the acousmata or
supposed sayings of the man himself
becomes especially important it's not
certain just how much of this is true
but it certainly paints a picture
first of all it seems that pythagoras
was vegetarian and that his way of life
included following a vegetarian diet
this was perhaps connected to the idea
of reincarnation as these two tend to be
connected sometimes
apart from this a lot of the rules that
the pythagoreans followed were connected
to religious ritual rules of conduct
that were to be followed in the temples
for example pythagoras didn't form a new
religion of his own they followed the
established greek religion at the time
but formulated particular rules
surrounding these religious rites for
example one wasn't allowed to enter the
temple barefoot you had to quote poor
libations to the gods from the ear or
handle of the cup you couldn't wear
images of the gods on your finger and
you couldn't sacrifice a white [ __ ]
fair enough you might think but there is
more and it gets weirder the
pythagoreans weren't allowed to bury
their dead in wool you had to put on the
right shoe first before the left foot
you weren't supposed to travel on public
roads and perhaps the strangers of them
all you were absolutely not allowed to
eat beans
beans were no good at all in an account
from the life of pythagoras we learn
about this bean hates as well as some of
the other rules quotes pythagoreans
enjoy and abstention from beings either
because they are like the privy parts or
because they are like the gates of hades
for this is the only plant that has no
joints or because they are destructive
unclear what that means or because they
are like the nature of the universe also
highly unclear or because they are
oligarchical being used in the choice of
rulers by lot things that fall from the
table they were told not to pick up to
accustom them to eating with moderation
or because such things mark the death of
someone
they must not touch a white [ __ ] because
this animal is sacred to the month and
is a supplient and supplication is a
good thing they must not break the loaf
nor must they divide the love which
brings them together others explain the
rule by reference to the judgment in
hades others explain that it is from the
loaf that the universe starts
other than these specific rules the
pythagoreans were expected to live a
somewhat austere and contemplative life
called step not over a balance in other
words be not covetous
poke not the fire with a sword in other
words do not vex with sharp words a man
swollen with anger pluck not the crown
in other words offend not against the
laws which are the crowns of cities or
again eat not hearts i vex not yourself
with grief sit not on the cornration i.e
live not in idleness when on a journey
turn not back in other words when you
are dying cling not to this life
if some of you know a thing or two about
the ancient world you might already be
thinking what i'm about to say a lot of
this reminds us of the so-called mystery
cults that existed in antiquity in the
hellenic world particularly indeed many
have compared and connected pythagoras
and the pythagoreans to the so-called
orphics another ancient mystery called
centered around the mythical figure of
orpheus these two groups share a lot of
features and it wouldn't be too far off
to call the pythagoreans a kind of
mystery cult
kirk raven and surefield describe the
orphic cult as such quote we can safely
say that the name of orpheus was
associated from at least the fifth
century on with the institution of
various rights which included initiation
into mysteries depicting terrors of
hades and whose object was to produce a
happy state for initiates before and
after death much the same can probably
be said for the pythagoreans they were a
group based on secret initiation and
which probably included special rituals
and practices alongside a general
ascetic way of life and the rules
mentioned above to help the initiate
purify his soul in some way in hopes of
a better afterlife or perhaps better
reincarnation there's a great aura of
esotericism over pythagoras in general
there's a lot we don't know about what
went on in the group and what their
teacher actually taught and this is
partially on purpose in fact another
thing that the pythagoreans became
famous for was their practice of silence
both in a literal sense of just
being silent and not talking some
sources claim that a person who wanted
to become a pythagorean had to observe a
five-year silence but secondly this
silence also includes a less literal way
of simply keeping their mouth shut about
the secrets of their master's teachings
there seems to have been certain
esoteric aspects to pythagoras ideas
that his followers weren't allowed to
disclose to the uninitiated it's the
kind of stuff that we both love and hate
to see understandably perhaps this
colorful little group attracted quite a
lot of attention at the time but not all
of it was positive indeed it is said
that the group came under attack at some
point in the last years of the 6th
century bc even to the point of violence
which forced pythagoras to relocate to
another greek city in italy called
metapontum where he's thought to have
died
somewhere around 490 bc
now you might be saying to yourself hold
on that's it there's nothing about
mathematics or geometry or any other
things that we associate with pythagoras
fair point and this is actually a very
difficult topic it is indeed true that
the name pythagoras is primarily
associated with philosophy that involves
numbers and the relationship and
importance in reality and in the world
and when anyone talks about later
philosophers you know as soon as they
say as soon as they say anything about
numbers like plato talking about the one
or the dyad as soon as numbers come into
the picture
people tend to say oh that's pythagorean
and a lot of the time these philosophers
would say the same plato himself was
often seen by his later followers as
following a pythagorean tradition of
wisdom but are these ideas actually
pythagorean as in originating in the
thought of pythagoras himself there is
very little in the direct sources about
his life that suggests that he had any
such ideas but that doesn't mean that
they aren't there at all we should be
careful not to apply later ideas
backward and indeed a lot of ideas that
later thinkers identified as pythagorean
were actually platonist and
anachronistically projected backwards to
pythagoras to legitimize them but at the
same time it is very possible that he
did have ideas about the fundamental
role of numbers in the cosmos indeed his
movement did survive after he died after
all some time in association with this
it is often thought that the movement
was divided into two general camps the
acousmaticoi which focused on the
religious rules and rituals that had
characterized the movement outwardly and
the mathematico who instead appears to
have focused on what we would refer to
as more
philosophical questions especially
including and here's the kicker
mathematics
even if this version of events isn't
based entirely on historical fact it's
hard to say
indeed in the fourth century just a
little bit later we have many people and
in this period we of course have a lot
more contemporary sources that refer to
these people we have people who
self-identify as pythagorean and whose
philosophy and his teachings resemble a
lot more what we would associate with
that name figures like philo laos argued
that reality was based on the concept of
the unlimited and limit and on the
harmony between the two making numbers
essential to understanding the cosmos
and arjitas made significant innovations
to mathematics and geometry both being
pythagoreans indeed the later
pythagoreans of the fourth century and
after its resurgence while later came to
be associated not only with that
characteristic way of life sometimes not
at all but with mystical and
philosophical ideas surrounding numbers
stuff like numerology geometry
arithmetic and music theory in the most
general sense pythagoreans believed that
reality was somehow made up of numbers
and this expresses itself in a multitude
of ways geometry is of course intimately
connected with numbers and math and the
pythagoreans develop geometric theories
that also seemingly explain the inner
workings of the cosmos especially in
works by people like phil laos who talk
about the unlimited and limit harmony
becomes important in pythagoreanism
mathematical and geometric ratios and
harmony are key to their philosophy and
is also directly connected to music
which is another subject with which
pythagoreanism is strongly associated
the pythagoreans develop significant
theories around music theory and are key
to the understanding of harmonic ratios
in music for example determining the
fourth fifth an octave in a scale the
harmony between musical notes and chords
is all based on mathematical ratios that
correspond to auditory experience and
lastly pythagoreanism is also associated
with a certain cosmology involving the
revolution of the planetary spheres as a
part of this mathematical harmonious
universe indeed the already mentioned
phila laos may have been one of the
first to suggest that the earth was not
in the center of the universe and some
even claimed that he affirmed the
heliocentric model based on his claim
that the earth revolves around the great
fire but this is of course
interpretation to connect it all again
the pythagoreans would hold to a theory
of the so-called music of the spheres
that the heavenly bodies as they revolve
and move across the sky and their
spheres create harmonious music
so all of it is connected to the
mathematical and geometric ideas
surrounding harmony
is it possible then that these ideas at
least some of them originate with
pythagoras himself
sure
in fact i think it would be a little
weird that so many who claim to follow
the teachings of pythagoras in later
centuries simply took those ideas
completely out of thin air so to say it
is quite possible that underneath the
ascetic ways of life and the ritual
rules pythagoras had more esoteric
secret teachings involving numbers and
harmony some later followers may have
chosen to follow only the ritualistic
and practical aspects of his thought
perhaps the so-called accusmaticoi while
others brought into light the more
speculative philosophical teachings the
so-called mathematico perhaps but it is
a difficult topic to wrap your head
around indeed sometime in the 4th
century the pythagoreans essentially
disappeared it is only a few centuries
later in the last years before the turn
of the common era that we see a
resurgence of what is known as
neo-pythagoreanism
and this isn't necessarily a school of
thought per se but a loose group of
individuals who all held pythagoras as a
central figure in the history of
philosophy perhaps even as the first
philosopher it is these so-called
neo-pythagoreans that might have
originated some of the ideas that we
most associate with pythagoreanism more
generally and which traces all later
wisdom such as the ideas of plato for
example back to the figure of pythagoras
the neopythagoreans were often heavily
influenced by platonism in fact and
later played an important part in the
development of so-called neoplatonism
but even aside from these philosophical
ideas the legacy of pythagoras continued
to
be carried forward in different ways
even in late antiquity there are people
who are associated with pythagoras or
associated with pythagoreanism simply
based on their behaviors and conduct
perhaps connected to that so-called
pythagorean way of life that he was so
strongly associated with these
pythagoreans were so identified because
they for example were vegetarians that
they were very simple clothing had
unkept hair and beard something that was
very unusual in roman times especially
and that they kind of smelled bad so
basically they were kind of like the
hippies of antiquity in other words the
legacy of the wonder working sage was
carried forward in many different and
diverse ways even many many centuries
after he died so pythagoras is an enigma
in more ways than one to me he's one of
the most interesting
characters one of the most interesting
figures in the whole tradition of
ancient greek philosophy and religion
there are perhaps many different sides
to his life and thoughts
sides that were carried forward by
different groups of his followers in
later centuries most of us might have
heard his name many times and been
taught that theorem in school which
probably wasn't his to begin with but
few of us have delved into the
mysterious wonder working semi-divine
sage side of him that is so fascinating
but that's why i'm here to provide you
with esoteric and strange goodies to
help you sleep at night for now i hope
you've learned something new about
pythagoras and his weird religious cults
we should definitely spend more episodes
in the future talking about those
mathematical
ideas that his later followers were
associated with something that i only
had time to touch on very briefly in
this episode it does indeed provide some
of the most interesting and foundational
ideas in the history of philosophy and
mysticism so as you contemplate that one
plus two plus three plus four equals 10
don't forget to leave a comment and like
the video if you feel like it deserved
it and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you